magnes i'm going to share
this session so it's a quantum session
so today we'll have a so i just make a
very short presentation and then we
start with the thoughts we have five
talks
i underline the name of the
speakers so we have a presentation on
new algorithm
but also new limitation and as well as a
new result on the model of computing
itself
so what is interesting i think that in
particular most of this result establish
and use new connection to classical
complexity theory
so the first talk considers the
difficulty of classical simulation of
quantum circuits
so this question is really hard and this
paper proves new harness results for a
specific type of classical simulations
so the second talk
will be on the other side namely it
establishes the limitations of some
quantum heuristics for hard classical
problems
and those heuristics
are very well adapted for near-term
quantum device
but this paper shows their limitations
so the third talk
will address the fundamental paradigm of
quantum circuits
so using intermediate measurement is a
way to reduce the number of qubits but
on the other hand it is crucial to avoid
intermediate measurements for any for
many aggregate purposes
such as control amplification for
instance
so surprisingly this paper provides a
simple compromise using a fresh study of
pseudorandom generator in the quantum
settings
the fourth talk we consider the study of
a noisy control circuits and in
particular or to control their errors so
it is known to control the total error
of any circuit
when each gate introduced an error below
some threshold
but it comes at the price of some space
and time overhead and this paper
establishes in particular some new
results on the space overhead
and the last talk
we consider the potential of quantum
property in a distributing
setting
so there have been recent development in
this area suggesting that the impact of
cartoon computing is both underestimate
underestimate and not well understood
for distributed computing and this paper
provide new results based on youtube so
it's a
larger
set of topics we covered today so i
stopped sharing my
screen
and this year you can start sharing your
screen so you have nine minutes
a mess and a small note
this when there is one minute left
okay you can see the screen you can see
the slide yes okay great
so hello and my name is joe pelag and
this is a talk about lower bound on
stabilizer rank this is based on a joint
work with emil spielke and ben livolk
so we'll start with the following
settings so we have a boolean function f
from f2 to the n to the complex field
and we want to express f as a linear
combination
of of base functions where our base
functions are minus 1 to the power of a
quadratic polynomial over s2
to the n so these representations
are a sort of a
general
generalization of the fourier
representation because if we only allow
lineal functions in the in the power
this would be exactly the fourier
representation of f now we have a larger
set of generator that we are interested
in
and there is an amazing fact
so we have this magic function we call f
of h we call it the magic function which
is as i define uh here
on the point x it outputs sine of pine
over h times the humming weight of x
times
a to the hamming weight of x times
cosine of pi over a
to the power of n minus the hamming
weight of x
and if we can express this magic
function f of h using a linear
combination of polynomially many
functions of the form minus 1 to the q
then t equals mp
so i think this fact is quite amazing
when it's stated like that and
the reason it's true is even
makes it even more amazing
and the rhythm is that if it's true we
can efficiently stimulate
bqp and even post bqp
using classical computer and this is
true due to the goddess nickname theorem
so if this is true we can official it we
can simulate efficiently every efficient
quantum
circuit
and the actual result allows more a
general a more general
class of functions as their base
function and
it allows us motivates the definition of
a stabilizer rank of a boolean function
which is denoted by v of f
and it's the minimal r such that we can
choose
our alpha in subspaces
all quadratic polynomials and our
linear polynomials
such that f can be represented as the
following linear combination
so for every
choice of an
a linear polynomial quadratic in an
alpha in subspace we take i to the power
of the linear polynomial times -1 to the
power of the quadratic polynomial
times the indicator function of the
alpha in subspace and for every choice
for every choice of linear function
quadratic polynomial and alpha and
subspace this product is called a
stabilizer function
and the stabilizer rank of the function
f
is the minimal r such that f can be
represented as a linear combination of
our stabilizer functions any our
stabilizer function
okay
and
they
stabilize the function the connection to
quantum computations so they'll
correspond to quantum states that are
called stabilizer states which are
stated are generated using cliff gates
for anyone who knows
and the fact is that we can classically
simulate any efficiently any efficient
quantum computation using time which is
polynomial in the stabilizer rate of the
magic function that i presented before f
of a f h
so
this is why this is correlated to
simulation of quantum computers
and
let me
take a few minutes and go over some
known results
so
before work the best lower bound
for the stabilizer rank of our magic
function
was the
square root of n due to bss in 2016
and there is an upper bound a
non-trivial upper bound of 2 to the
alpha n where alpha
is log of 3 over 4
due to qpg in 2021 and this is the last
of a long line of work that uh
proving
this kind of result for smaller and
smaller alphas values of alpha
and as i mentioned before the stabilizer
rank of the magic function
is super polynomial unless p equals then
b
so this is due to hn's s in 2020
when we assume the exponential time
hypothesis then the stabilizer rank of
the magic function is indeed exponential
and this is due to mt in 2020 and again
hns in 2020
and
if we
as so as i mentioned before the
stabilizer rank of a function
is the minimal
number of
of summons in a linear representation of
stabilizer functions that uh generates
our
that generate the
the function so if in the linear
combination we only allow small
coefficients
then the measure is indeed exponential
and this is again due to bss 2016 and bg
in 2016 as well
and in this work we showed we gave a
lower bound of linear lower bound for
the stabilizer rank of the magic
function
and we also showed
um
a lower bound of square root of n over
log n for approximations of the
stabilizer functions that by that we
mean that any approximation in l2 norm
that is close to our function
up to
up to some constant delta small constant
delta also a large stabilizer rank
and
yes so this problem is also correlated
or
to a problem
in
analysis of boolean functions called the
quadratic quadratic uncertainty
principle
so
in this question we ask we eliminate the
offering subspace and the linear
functions and we only can say consider
function of the form minus 1 to the q
where q is quadratic
and we ask how many
summons must be in the linear
representation of the end function
and the conjecture is that you need
exponentially many summons
and
so the best known lower bound for this
a conjecture is n over two
and it is still open to to prove a super
linear log bond for any explicit
function
uh so any explicit boolean function
uh
there are no better than linear load
bounds
the best that we know is that william
williams in 2018 gave er so a function
in np
for every k he gave a function in np
that needs at least and to decay summons
in the
in the
uh representation in this kind of a
presentation
so this is correlated but it is less
generalized general
than the stabilizer length model as
indeed the stabilize the rank of the end
function is one
so when we allow the alpha in subspace
we can just pinpoint one point
and get exactly the end function so this
is similar but less general than the
stabilizer function
and
i won't go into the details of the proof
here but you are more than welcome to
watch the full video but i'll go over
the open problems that we mentioned
so of course improving the lower bounds
for the stabilizer rank the two
follow-up work to our works due to
labive and lovitz stefan
and they used different techniques but
uh
proved the same lower bounds
and again improved the lower bounds for
the quadratic insanity principle and we
believe that these two problems our
technique
uh
made us think that these
two problems are somewhat correlated so
maybe improving one should help you
improve the other or the ideas should be
similar and so thank you for listening
and i hope you enjoyed
thanks a lot is there any question in
the
audience can
eventually write it in the chat if it's
easier
what
no i mean
if someone has a question you can write
it yeah please yeah
sorry just had a quick question i didn't
fully follow how the stabilizer rank
related to um
the goddess ben knell theorem like um
the function f what exactly are you
decomposing like is it so the function
if if you know i didn't mention it
because
i didn't have time but the function was
fine
uh is the
is the function is a representation of
the of a boolean function as the n
stands for of the
h
state or the magic state of h which is
the
which is what you get by applying uh the
zero uh state to the t uh
state if you know uh
the d state so and dot neil
that you can simulate
clifford circuits
so if you
and so if you can replace the age gates
uh h states with uh some small linear
combination of uh
clifford state and you can simulate any
circuit
thank you
you're welcome
sorry another question
yes
we have to move on so maybe very quick
question
yeah so i my question was if we just
look at representing functions as
uh linear combinations of the indicators
of affine spaces
then is it then is it easy to prove a
lower bound on the number of such
indicators needed for any explicit
function
uh yeah i think it should be
it should be easier but i don't have any
function in mind i think it should be
maybe majority should be
that maybe the majority function should
require a lot of uh
but i'm not there i'm not confident
enough
okay yeah
okay so thank you
thanks a lot so you can stop sharing
your your screen
kunal is your
you have the token
good you can start
can you hear me okay
oh shoot
so hi there my name is canal uh i'm
presenting a work uh from last june on
algorithmic limitations for maximum cut
on high girth graphs
this is joint with bose barrack
so i'll give a brief overview of the
problem i'll talk about the state of the
art for max cut and give a brief
discussion of the main technique then
you can watch a longer version in the
video
so what is the maximum cut problem just
for completeness sake if you take a
graph
and you want to split it into two parts
and you want to maximize the number of
edges between partitions this problem is
np hard so
most people study approximation
algorithms
there's a very popular algorithm called
the semi-definite programming algorithm
or using a semi-definite relaxation it's
a classical algorithm but it's not local
and i'm going to be interested in local
algorithms primarily comparing classical
local algorithms and quantum local
algorithms and so
what do i mean by local
um let's call an algorithm local with
respect to some graph
if every vertex is labeled with some
from some id distribution
and then you recompute the label using
only the radius k neighborhood in the
graph
so
at small k you can't see the whole graph
so it's kind of like a limited model of
computation
you can think of factors by id
algorithms but also there's a variant of
this where you can think of quantum
computation as being local
and
the thought is you know how how powerful
these local algorithms are there
anything you can say about
maybe the limitations of these local
algorithms
um the reason i bring up local
algorithms for quantum computations
because there's these noisy intermediate
scale quantum devices or these nisk
devices that people talk about i would
say you'll see them through the next
decade and these every operation you run
on a quantum device is a computer is is
noisy so there's only so many operations
you can run before the noise overwhelms
the signal
and so one way to model this is kind of
with low depth circuits or kind of let's
call them local quantum algorithms where
you can't actually have a circuit depth
that's too large
um and so one question is are these nisk
devices which we have for the next
decade or so are they useful for
anything and one real question is are
they useful for combinatorial
optimization
and
there's a popular
algorithm style called the qaoa that's
kind of been making rounds in industry
and in
national labs but there's not a ton of
theoretical
evidence to show that it's useful or not
useful
and so one way to model this is kind of
with
a graphic that we're calling nisk
optimization advantage
so i'll take a little time to explain
this figure the green line is this
any quantum local algorithm that's
like one step like the locality is depth
one
and the yellow line is any locality at
constant depth
and the black line is any classical
algorithm and so across all csp
instances are there any csp instances
any instances of problems where quantum
local algorithms at constant depth are
somehow
achieving higher values than classical
algorithms
and so this yellow crossing the black
line we don't know if this happens
if this happens this is like a lot of
theoretical evidence to suggest that
quantum computers of today are useful
for combinatory optimization
so i'll talk a little bit about what's
going on with maximum cut it's a very
commonly studied problem it's an old
problem
um
instead of looking at the approximate
ratio approximation ratio i'm looking at
a different metric the metric i'm
looking at is cut fraction so
approximation ratio is like the percent
of optimal you can get on a particular
graph
instead i'm just taking you know high
girth or random graphs and trying to see
how many edges can i cut
so the maximum amount of edges you can
cut as n and d grow large on a random
graph
is half the edges plus
some constant over square root d
and there's a connection to statistical
physics which c is you know the best you
see you can get is like 0.76 it's uh
related to the pre-c value
um a particular spin glass problem so
i'm plotting on this on this plot the
value of c
and it turned out there was a time when
the qa away at the lowest depth
was
very was the most powerful algorithm on
this metric you know to achieve like
0.31 or something
and it was a little confusing you know
is the qaoa the best algorithm we have
it's a local algorithm it's a depth one
that seems really surprising
so it turns out the answer is no um
maybe maybe obviously but the answer is
no
and there is a classical algorithm that
is also one local
that achieves slightly higher cut
fraction and expectation
and so you might say is this true at
higher depth and it turns out so i did
some work last year that the answer is
no again for two
and i should mention that this qaoa is
relatively challenging to analyze at
high depth which is what makes the
theory limited
so in this work amongst other things the
the most exciting thing i think
in this work is we were able to show a
bound on all one local algorithms
whether they're quantum or classical
any algorithm that is
limited in its information cannot
achieve
higher than 0.71 so it's a non-trivial
bound it's not you know it's not really
tight but it is a
a non-trivial bound and the technique is
i think completely new where you're
going to use uh correlations of random
walks and use that to
bound um
kind of like the expected cut fraction
you can get or the chance the chance
you're actually going to cut an edge on
a random graph
so this is kind of a cool new technique
that could be valuable in other settings
or maybe again on maximum cut
so i'll give an overview of the main
technique um
it's i'll just talk very briefly about
it
um so the theorem that we have is like
you have a high growth graph and you
have a one local algorithm it could be
quantum could be classical
and
the maximum expected cut fraction you
can have is half
plus c over square root d where c is
bounded
so how do we get this bound
so i told you i'm looking at
correlations of random walks so when you
take a random walk you know s steps
you're going to end up some distance
away from where you started
and when you
you can calculate the chance of how far
away you um
how far away you go
so when your distance one away this
value the correlation of distance one is
actually is related to the maximum cut
because if the two labels are related
you know if the two labels are the same
then they're going to end up in the same
partition so the edge will not be cut
and if the two labels are different then
the edge will be cut and they'll be in
different partitions
so this distance one thing
is really
is related to the the value of the csp
that we're looking at the cut fraction
but if you go beyond the like cone of
this local algorithm so
beyond 2k
there's gonna be zero correlation
and so there's a tension between walking
too far and you have zero correlation
and walking very close and that's
actually the value you're looking for
so we're able to kind of cleverly
construct a random walk um
to
bound uh
the kind of
the correlation between adjacent
adjacent labels and this bound to square
root two over d becomes you know you can
relate it to this constant
and so one question is like can you
generalize this technique in other
problems and
or at higher depth and we weren't able
to do that i think it's totally possible
that it could be done
but for the story we have here you know
the real question is you know
do quantum local algorithms are they
effective on maximum cut
and it turns out actually in november
asymptotically the answer is no like
classical algorithms achieve optimal
performance on maximum cut on random
graphs through a recent paper uh with
montanari
um
but it might be possible that like
there's no combinatorial optimization
problem that quantum local algorithms
are useful
and so
one really important thing is i think
theoretically is to kind of either
say yes or no should we be spending so
much money on quantum computing for
combinatory optimization when there's no
evidence to support it in fact it might
be like a waste of funds and we could
use the money somewhere else
so thanks i'll take any questions and
i'm actually at uchicago now i'm a phd
student there and so
you can write to me or
talk to me thanks
thank you we have time for one question
maybe stop sharing your screen
okay
this meeting is being recorded
okay so maybe we move to the next talk
uma can you share your screen please
sure
there is a yeah there is a question by
sevag maybe
um
so in november there's a paper i'll just
link the paper in the chat
that for maximum cut on random graphs
as the random graph gets very large both
n and d get large there is a uh message
passing approximate message packing
algorithm that achieves optimal
so thank you you know race that we've
been doing
like uh trying to compare quantum and
classical algorithms at least on random
graphs like
the race to me is over like uh classical
algorithms are able to achieve it now
that like um
there still may be other csps where uh
quantum local algorithms are are
valuable but it's not clear
what
thank you
so uma can you unmute and share your
screen please
perfect you can start
uh okay
so i'll be talking about eliminating
intermediate measurements using pseudo
random generators this is a joint work
with ron ross
so here are our results
our first result is that we show a way
to defer intermediate measurements for
quantum algorithms
in a space efficient and time efficient
way
more precisely for time t spaces
algorithms we show that you can
eliminate intermediate measurements in
time t poly s and space s log t
our second result is that we study
pseudorandom generators for quantum
algorithms that can read classical
random bits
we show that the variant of the
empaglias or nissan witness and
generator force such algorithms
so now let me describe these results in
more detail
so first what is a quantum algorithm of
space s and time t
so there are a lot of intricacies
involved in defining such algorithms but
for this talk for the sake of simplicity
just think of a quantum algorithm as a
quantum circuit
so space s and time t corresponds to
having s qubits and applying t operators
what kind of operators are allowed
this is a really important question and
based on the kind of operators we allow
we could get potentially different
models of computation
so on the one hand we have the unitary
model so fix any set of gates that is
universal for quantum computation
unitary gates for example the hadamard
and the tofoli gate and look at circuits
that are built using these gates
this gives rise to the unitary model of
quantum computation
on the other hand you have the unital
model where you can perform measurements
during computation
so measurements are not unitary
operators and typically we only allow
measurements to be performed at the end
of the computation but in this model you
are allowed to perform measurements
during computation
this is what we call the unitard model
note that in this model you can store
measurement outcomes
by copying the measurement outcome onto
a fresh qubit but you will have to pay
in terms of the space required so this
qubit is going to count towards the
space
so you can store measurement outcomes
but you'll have to pay for the space to
store these measurement outcomes
so given these two models the big
question here is this are these two
models different
given a quantum algorithm with
intermediate measurements can we
simulate it by quantum algorithm without
intermediate measurements
do intermediate measurements give power
to quantum computation
this is a really fundamental question in
quantum computing
this also has connections to
reversibility of computation
so this question is asking can we
simulate the irreversible operation of a
measurement by doing reversible
operations in an efficient way
so what do we know about this question
one very basic principle in quantum
computing is the principle of deferred
measurements
this says that instead of measuring a
qubit you can copy that qubit onto a
fresh qubit and ignore that fresh qubit
for the rest of the computation
this implies that to defer measurements
for time t spaces algorithms you can do
it in time t and space s plus t
so why is there a space s plus t because
the original algorithm could perform up
to t measurements and to defer each of
these measurements you need a fresh
qubit
note that often it is the case that s is
much smaller than law sss is much
smaller than t so for example think of
the setting when s is poly log t
then the space blows up from s to s plus
t
so this is an exponential blob in space
so one can ask is there a version of the
principle of deferred measurements that
is space efficient can we differ
intermediate measurements in a space
efficient manner
this was an open question until last
year it was resolved by these two works
independently that indeed you can defer
measurements in a space efficient way
so for time t spaces algorithms you can
differ intermediate measurements in
space s plus log t and time polynomial
and t and 2 to the s
typically s is at least log t so the
overhead in space is constant
however the overhead in time in the
simulation is really large
so think of the setting when s is
much larger than log t
in this case you have a runtime of 2 to
the s which is quasi polynomial overhead
so with regards to eliminating
intermediate measurements the best known
ways to eliminate intermediate
measurements required either time due to
the s or space t
this is the issue that we address in our
work
so we show a way to defer intermediate
measurements
in a space efficient and time efficient
manner
so we show that to defer measurements
for time t spaces algorithms you can do
it in time t poly s and space s log t
in other words we give a version of the
principle of deferred measurements that
is both space efficient and time
efficient simultaneously
so this result for example implies that
quantum algorithms of poly logarithmic
space and polynomial time do not require
intermediate measurements
so this is our first result
let me now describe our second result
and also the connection between our
first result and the second result
the connection is in the following
powerful observation
intermediate measurements and randomness
are equivalent
first intermediate measurements can be
used to generate randomness
so take a qubit in the state 0 apply a
hadamard and measure it
the measurement outcome is going to be a
uniformly random bit
and to generate more random bits you'd
again over and over apply the hadamard
and the measurement gates
interestingly the other direction also
holds that is randomness can be used to
simulate intermediate measurements
so we show that instead of measuring a
qubit you can equivalently apply a
controlled unitary on that qubit where
the control is on a uniformly random bit
thus intermediate measurements and
randomness are equivalent
the proof of this is a simple
calculation
let's see how it is used
so by what i just said given any quantum
algorithm with intermediate measurements
you can write down an equivalent quantum
algorithm without intermediate
measurements but with access to
uniformly random bits
therefore the problem of eliminating
intermediate measurements is equivalent
to the problem of removing random bits
or in other words the problem of
derandomization
the idea is then to replace these
uniformly random bits by pseudo random
bits
so these are bits which contain very few
bits of true uniform randomness and the
rest of the bits are actually a function
of these few random
bits this leads us naturally to the
concept of a pseudo random generator so
let me briefly describe what a pseudo
random separator is it is basically a
function that stretches a very few
random bits to a large number of random
bits and the property we want of this
function is the following
in the ideal case you have an algorithm
of space s time t you're giving it a
uniformly random string over a large
universe and you're looking at the
output
on the other hand you have this
algorithm f you're taking a few random
bits stretching it using the generator
and then feeding it to the algorithm
the property we want out of a prg is
that the behavior of this algorithm in
these two different situations is close
is nearly identical
so we want to simulate the behavior of
the algorithm on a large number of
random bits by using a few random bits
and stretching it using the pseudo
random generator
so now i am ready to state our second
main result
we study the impogrious on nissan with
distance generator this is a famous
classical generator for time t space as
classical algorithms
we show that a variant of this generator
actually works for quantum algorithms of
space as time t that read classical
random bits
so to the best of our knowledge this is
the first such result of its kind
quantum prgs for quantum algorithms that
read classical random which is something
people have not studied a lot before
because presumably quantum algorithms
can generate perfect randomness
but this relies on their ability to
perform intermediate measurements so we
think in situations when the quantum
algorithm cannot perform intermediate
measurements or it cannot be relied upon
to do what it's supposed to do we think
that prgs might find applications in
these settings
so this brings me to the end of my talk
let me just put up the slide to
summarize what i've said
so any questions
in
analogy uh in analogy to the sort of
conjectured improvements to inw in the
classical space bounded case could we
hope to eventually get a simulation with
like order grass space rather than s-log
key uh sorry uh what is the context
regarding the classical oh i'm just um
in the classical setting inw has a seed
of
so like quadratically worse than what we
would hope for if you have a log space
algorithm and so in the quantum case is
there an equivalent hope to
[Music]
improve our our space overhead by a
quadratic i guess i'm thinking of s is
log t but
by by
going down from s log t to just s
oh uh
yeah so this really relies on the kind
of pseudo-random generators we use so
so in the inw case you have this
recursion recursive construction built
on the extractor property
and here we are able to use a quantum
extractor to have that kind of property
so i think it would really depend on the
kind of generator that you use
um
there is no we don't see a black box way
to translate prgs from classical to
quantum but depending on the kind of
extractors or what kind of objects are
used it's possible that they do
excellent
you also have a i guess a simple
question in the chat do you read it or
uh let me
can you see it or i can't read it
it's the classical randomness read in by
the classical turing machine that
generates a description of the circuit
uh so no we require that the turing
machine that generates a description of
the circuit is deterministic so it's
deterministic log space
um
so the randomness is only for the
circuit only the circuit takes in the
randomness
i hope that answers the question and
there is another question how do your
results compare with a fifth and main
rip screen so this is a good question so
um in this talk i've said all the
operators are already unitary
measurements and unitary gates and
measurements
but um this fiferman and ram scrim they
consider a model where you are also
allowed to reset a qubit
so this is in some sense uh taking a
qubit in an arbitrary state and mapping
it to the zero state and they show that
even such kind of operations can be
removed in this same overhead in space
and time so their result is stronger
than our result
however if you look at this setting when
um
so that still requires a two to the s
overhead so even to eliminate
intermediate measurements you require
two to the s overhead in uh
in time so to the best of our knowledge
uh our results are this new work is kind
of incomparable to that because we get a
better runtime dependence but our space
is s times log t instead of s plus log t
so it's in some sense incomparable
thank you
so it's time to
move to the second chooser's next talk
allah can you
unmute and share your screen please
can you see my screen
not yet
yeah
you are not in full screen but that's
okay
it's perfect you can start
hi everyone uh so i'm going to talk
about a joint work with omar faldi and
alexander muller hermes on a space
overhead of alternate quantum
computation
so uh one of the fundamental resulting
theory of quantum computation
is the fault iron threshold theorem
which states that you can do arbitrarily
long uh computations on a
noisy quantum computer as long as the
noise level in your
computer is below a constant level
uh which is known as the threshold value
and indeed you can achieve fault
tolerance with a
very reasonable overhead in space and
time
so there exists a faltering scheme which
uh
given a circuit of depth n
left c and it's n
uh uh
outputs at fault tolerance we get
of uh depth t prime and uh
with n prime with only a poly
logarithmic overhead in n and t
and here we define the space overhead as
the ratio n prime over n
and time overhead is defined as t prime
over
t so uh
more recently goddess man showed that
assuming a good a quantum error
correcting code to exist
then uh satisfying certain properties
exist
then you can achieve a
constant overhead fault tolerance
uh asymptotically
and more recently uh
fuzzy atoll proved that
quantum expander could actually satisfy
these desired properties and they
actually showed that you can indeed
achieve a constant space overhead
however unlike the threshold theorem
which
applies to arbitrarily long quantum
circuits uh the proposed scheme only
applies to three cats that have depth at
most polynomial in the bit
and this motivated us to think about uh
the following question
so given a noise model
how does the necessary overhead to
achieve tolerance grow as a function of
the circuit size
so
in recent years a lot of effort has been
devoted to
introducing
new recipes for fault tolerance
but a study of fundamental limitations
of alternate computation has received
far less attention and
this is partly because
uh it's really difficult to uh provide a
definition for
uh fault on quantum computation
in the first place in order to be able
to actually talk about our properties
like general properties or limitations
of
fault tolerance schemes
so listed uh some relevant results on
limitations of noisy quantum circuits uh
these are very interesting results but
they have some limitations for example
most of these words
study like assume a classical
computation is also noisy
and we know that today we can do
classical computation with uh
practically perfect accuracy so this is
not a realistic assumption
and um in fact uh the limitations shown
in these works uh feel toward even like
if we assume that
uh classical computation is noiseless
even for our virtually long tickets
uh
most of these results only apply to
circuits under strong noise and in
particular noise levels beyond the
threshold value
the circuit models considered in these
papers are
sometimes uh
restrictive so uh the circuit like the
gate set is sometimes limited
uh the
output of the circuit is assumed to be
uh obtained by measuring for example the
constant number of qubits
or fresh fresh ancelor qubits are not
available during the computation
and uh finally
in most of these works
uh
only deep rising noise is studied
um
so in this work we prove a lower bound
on the space overhead of quadrant
quantum computation
and uh we try to address these
limitations
so before stating our result i need to
define our model
so a quantum circuit in our model is a
is an ordered sequence of uh quantum
channels or completely positive and
trace preserving linear maps
uh acting on a potentially non-trivial
input system
and uh
so in our model uh we distinguish
between classical and quantum subsystems
and uh so the number of qubits may vary
in different time steps so we can
introduce fresh ancelor qubits or
measure qubits
um
now
for the noise model we consider iid
noise where in each time step every
qubit is subject to some noise channel n
and we allow classical computation to be
free and noiseless
and uh
since in our model vlog arbitrary
quantum gates
uh unitary noise is not really an
interesting uh noise model because it
can be perfectly cancelled in each time
step by the case
so we focus on uh non-unitary noise
okay so our main result is the following
let n be a non-unitary cubic channel
then for any photon scheme against iid
noise modeled by the noise channel n
the number of physical qubits is at
least the maximum of the following two
bounds
the first bound is alpha n times lag t
where alpha is a constant depending only
on the channel n and the second bound is
the
inverse of the quantum capacity of the
noise channel
times n
where the quantum capacity is the
maximum rate at which you can transmit
quantum information reliably over the
channel
so in order to prove this theorem we
first need to define what we mean by a
photon scene
and uh in this work we consider a very
natural and
simple
fault tolerance model with minimal
assumptions
and in our model a photon scheme is a
circuit encoding map associated with a
family of quantum error correcting codes
and we only require voltron's theme to
be able to implement uh arbitrary
logical circuits on encoded data
in other words uh we allow the encoding
of the input state and the out the
decoding of the output state to be
perfect
so
our second bound in terms of the quantum
capacity is actually a direct
consequence of our model of tolerance so
it's easy to show
so next i'm going to explain how we uh
prove uh the the first pound
let's give you some idea
so we consider uh circuits of the
following form
of uh with n and depth t
in which in every time step uh the
registers are partitioned into a and b
subsystems and the circuit is only
allowed to act locally on the a and b
parts and communicate only classically
between the two parts of the signal
so intuitively such a circuit shouldn't
be able to preserve entanglement between
the two parts for a virtually long time
and
our contribution is actually a
quantitative quantitative version of
this statement
and in particular we show that
the amount of entanglement
decays by a factor of one minus p to the
n
in every time step where p is a constant
depending only on the noise channel n
and uh here we quantify entanglement
using uh
the chi-squared divergence from the set
observable state
and in case you're not familiar with
this it's not really important it's just
a measure
we use to quantify
entanglement
and
using this lemma we can obtain an
exponential upper bound on the maximal
length of computation against amplitude
damping noise
and this actually resolves an open
question by
uh ben or atoll uh from 2013.
and uh okay let me finish by some open
questions
so of course we can try to
improve our lower bounds
uh in our model we allow uh gates to act
uh simultaneously on all the qubits but
in reality we are always restricted to
act uh locally and on a limited number
of qubits so it would be interesting to
see uh how it like geometric locality
restrictions affect the
uh the space overhead of alternate
computation
and uh it would be also interesting to
study ii noise model by channels in
higher damage
thanks i think that's all i wanted to
say
thank you
so maybe uh
one quick question
okay so in fact we are running out of
time so
good thank you so
it's time to move to the last talk can
you unshare yeah dean can you unmute and
share your screen please
yes
okay can you see my screen
not yet
yes it's okay now you can start
okay great thanks for the introduction
and so yeah this is uh this is work on
quantum distributed algorithms for
detection of clicks and it's work joint
work with karen orr from swan wrote that
and basically we asked the question well
when we have lots of quantum computers
and we all have to talk to one another
how can we detect clicks faster
okay
so the problem that we tackle is
subgraph existence this type these types
of problems are very common in
distributed computing and also in
sequential computing and they say the
following we have some large input graph
and we have some small subgraph for
example a triangle and we're tasked with
doing one or three things either
detecting saying if the small subgraph
exists anywhere in the infograph
counting which is giving an exact number
of the number of times the subgraph
exists in the infographic
or listing we're listening is the most
challenging version and we're tasked
with finding every single instance of
the subgraph in the infographic in the
distributed setting each one of these
problems has its own definition for
example for the listing setting
where we we have that every node in the
graph there's some computation unit
and every computation unit outputs some
list of the instances of the subgraph
that it sees and it has to be that all
the lists put together or is exactly the
list of all the instances of the
subgraph and the input graph and so
that's a problem that we try to solve
so what do we do in this paper our main
result
is showing how we can take algorithms
for listing clicks of a certain size for
example some size p
and then using nested grover searches
nested quantum grover searches in order
to detect clicks of larger sizes
the way that we do that is we introduce
a new distributed framework for using
these nested quantum searches it's the
first time as far as we're aware that
the quantum searches are nested into one
another in the distributed setting and
we also do this in a way such that it
doesn't require any quantum knowledge
whatsoever we provide some black box and
now any distributed researcher can go
ahead and use this black box in order to
develop new algorithms
so just as a taste of the results that
we show we for example take a known
algorithm for listing all triangles in n
to the one over three rounds and this is
a classical algorithm
and we turn it into an algorithm for
detecting if there's a click of size 4
in the same round complexity
in general this is the result that we
get the blue line shows the runtime for
listing clicks of a certain size in the
non-quantum setting in the classical
setting
and the red line shows how long it takes
us to detect the same click size using
quantum computation
and so as we said for triangles we're
able to detect if there's a triangle n
to the one over five we're classically
finding all triangles takes n to the one
over three and so forth we go ahead and
we show this for any general size p for
any size click
interestingly the blue line is also
lower bound in the quantum setting
listing clicks in the quantum set in the
quantum distributed setting takes the
runtime of the blue line and we
basically show here a separation for
clicks of all sizes so that means that
in the quantum distributed setting that
we work
detected if there's a click of a certain
size is faster than listing
this was unknown so so we showed this
frog clicks except for for size three
precisely it was known in previous work
which was also co-authored by the
session chair
and
so
this separation is very interesting
because in the classical setting this is
unknown we don't know if this currently
holds in the classical setting except
for for triangles which is known in the
classical setting for clicks of large
size four and above this separation
exists in the quantum setting and
non-classical as far as we know
so we'll start
with just a small taste of how we do
this and you can see the the rest of the
talk recording if you want to see more
just a small
how do we do this trick how do we go
from listening click some size p so for
example the tech thing clicks of size p
plus one
so grover search is a well-known quantum
algorithm which was developed many years
ago and basically says if we have some
array and we know that one of the values
is one in the array then we can find
this index and n to the n squared of n
time where n is the length of the array
more generally it says that we have some
function f and we can feed it some input
and if there's a if it's a boolean
function and there is some value that
outputs one then we can find some x star
in square root of the size of the input
domain time
it was also recently shown how to do
this in the class and imagination
setting in the distributed setting we
have some some graph of nodes which
communicate with one another
and we we select some leader node
we give this leader node some input x
in order to evaluate the function on x
the input node the leader node together
with the other nodes communicate for
some c number of computation rounds
and after c rounds the leader node knows
f of x
so this is how we evaluate the
distributed function
now if we do this with quantum
computation
then we can say that the leader node can
perform the distributed grover search
locally where every time we need to
query the function it communicates with
its neighbors and so
solving using rover search in the
distributed setting
takes c to c rounds where c is the
number of times to check a single input
times the square root of the input
domain size
what we show with this for example we
take an algorithm which performs listing
of clicks for example listing of clicks
of size 4 would ensure that every single
click of size 4 is no to some node in
the graph for example this orange click
will be known to the purple node
so we run some known classical algorithm
for listing clicks of size 4.
then we go ahead and we show that if we
want to check for single specific node
does this node extend some click of size
4 to a click of size 5.
we show that if it's neighbors broadcast
to the entire graph that they neighbor
this node then it's possible in all of
one rounds
to detect if
if this node extends some known click to
click on larger size
since we have to check this for every
single node and we can run a grover
search on this so when we have nodes it
takes square root of n number of rounds
in order to check if there's some node
in the graph which can extend a given
click of size p
to a click of size p plus one
and so what we get here is that if we
want to detect clicks of size plus one
the runtime that it takes is the same
runtime as listing all clicks of size p
and add square root of n rounds to that
and so already here we show a separation
for all clicks of all sizes for the
technical clicks of all cycles
we go ahead and extend this to nesting
the grover searches which basically
means we take the same algorithm here
and we note that we had some classical
setup here
and then we did some classical checking
algorithm
and we ran some quantum search over this
classical checking algorithm basically
what we go ahead and we now do is we say
what if we replace the checking
algorithm instead of using a classical
one we use a quantum checking algorithm
and this is where we get nested grover
searches so we perform some classical
setup time and then we perform some
grover search and then inside the
checking procedure we perform again some
classical checkup time and then another
quantum rover search
and the reason and this this speeds up
our detection even faster and the reason
that it works is because it's based on
some nice distributed trick where the
trick is that in the distributed setting
we pay just for communication between
the nodes
and so when a node learns some
information classically on one step and
the future distributed checks
with
the grover searchers it can reuse this
information without having to pay for it
again
basically what we get is that we show
the following result that we can extend
click detect click listing for size p
by any t that we want
and so forth and as the click size grows
larger it becomes worth extending more
finally we go ahead and we say well we
had all this was with some any black box
listening algorithm we didn't assume
anything on the listing algorithm itself
we go ahead and we open this black box
and we create a tailor-made specific
quantum listing algorithm that works
together with our quantum searches and
this makes us even faster
and so just
a fine result that we show we also show
that it's based on some of the work that
we show here and some results from
recent papers we show that it's
difficult to show lower bounds for the
technical clicks in the quantum
distributed setting
because it will imply results in
circuit complexity
so to summarize we show how to extend
classical algorithms which list clicks
of a certain size to those
in quantum setting which detect clicks
of larger sizes
in order to do it even faster we open up
the black box and create a specific
tailor-made quantum listing algorithm
that works even fast with our detection
algorithms and we also attach onto this
some results that we show for hardness
of showing lower bounds in the setting
thank you
so there is time for one question
yes martin
yeah thanks uh it ties a bit into the
slide before the summary how specific
are your results uh to cliques so what
about detecting other substructures
okay
so
this is also general question for the
distributed settings so currently most
of the results are clicks and cycles
where the the
those are mostly results that are
currently
that are currently known where the big
difference between them is that in the
distributed setting you really as the
information is not is more local you can
run much faster typically
and
for detecting clicks because every
single node has to be connected to one
another it really helps for detecting
cycles for example you get into problems
because you have to learn information
that's not directly known to one of your
neighbors for example and so that
becomes even more complicated but most
of the results are around clicks and
cycles our results are specifically for
clicks we also have some results on
cycles but they're not some
there are some adaptations of the
existing cycle detection algorithms
and we weren't in this paper though
thank you
so there's no more question
so this concludes the session so thanks
to everyone thanks to the authors
so we have a break and then there is a
session for graduating bits
see you later
you